take a look at rather than designing  realistic goals is how can you design  the most inspiring schedule for your day  and your week so that you're optimizing  who you are and what you can contribute  to this world and i can tell you that  one of the biggest differences that i  made that allowed me to create the  results that i'm really proud of is  designing my day with intention  and being really really clear about when  i'm going to bed and when i'm waking up  you know computers are made to run  non-stop right we can turn them on we  can hammer away all day with not taking  a break and pretty much they're going to  keep running day after day because  they're a machine  but we humans are built differently